nous on est un petit peu un comptoir de
vente mais c'est salim en terre parce
que la moindre opportunité on s'empare
du trône et quand je dis opportunité je
puisse dire complot et quand je dis on
c'est plus de moi et quand je dis trop
dresser ah bah non c'est trop dur
alors pourquoi les potions en fait moi
un matin il ya un ami qu'il aime voir le
dit ouais je crois que j'ai fait est
annoncé tout machin qui partent chercher
une potion était alors en fait les
potions donc mon pote est mort et je me
suis dit dépression va les faire sur
place parce que si nous on veut acheter
des épées ou des arbalètes en a partout
alors que les potions yade vient pas on
les fabrique ici
aleph du baume du tigre vous en avez
banon la fabrique ici et ça son royaume
personnes en fait un truc à nous ça
c'est la guerre les gens sont souvent
mal du conte un petit peu en rupture de
stock aujourd'hui on reçoit un envoyé de
la maison des loups du nord je les
trouve sympa mais un peu les cheveux
gras et moi ça me gêne quand ils disent
des trucs sérieux vous présenterez nos
excuses à votre seigneur les plantes
n'ont pas donné ce qu'on espérait cela n
fashion frax le chef des lots est mort à
la période des troubles et fonio le
temps presse mais j'ai pas un nouveau
roi du nord se trahissent la main du roi
saint emilion le liant le cerf le
gallois qui lourd guy lourd pour moi
c'était des comme des toutes petites
chaussures en pot fous rires donc lui
biello et moi j'ai hiver arrive je sais
pas ce que vous répétez ça depuis le
début mai déjà
est ce qu'on est sûr de ça parce que moi
je me demande est ce qu'on pourrait pas
décaler l'hiver parce que vous en termes
de moalla vous allez tous me octobre
novembre cherchent à ses passes
halloween
quand un client a un truc en tête à
lévis a réussi à faire venir un guerrier
de la région la plus mystérieuse du
royaume
s'il accepte de nous aider on est sauvé
j'ai trop facilement son moitié sorcier
et poitiers garer j'adore et il parle un
peu comme des demeurés 1,6 man l'homme
doit tuer l'homme a besoin du poison qui
tue l'homme fort bien des bleus guerrier
et justement j'ai plusieurs poison à
vous proposer et notamment une petite
plante verte
si on utilise bien tu peux pas l'homme a
changé de visage
ouais ça m'a changé de visage la map a
prévenu du coup le mât flipper si vous
avez besoin d'autre chose
j'ai aussi un poison extrêmement mortel
qui peut à parme en le mettant des ducks
l'homme est cool l'homme a besoin de 30
secondes est chaud il fait chaud on est
sauvé le guerrier a accepté d'offrir du
leff avoir des changes de poison l'homme
est super on est de retour dans la
course au trône et ça c'est la bonne
nouvelle du jour avec ta baisse du prix
du foie
[Musique]